normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government I want
to pull up this tweet from Step Crowder
it is from his discussion with Alex
Jones this morning he says quote this
was a strategic Democratic party in PR
operation Alex Jones clears the air on
why his Twitter account was banned how
it feels to be reinstated on X by Elon
as well as what his future plans are so
let me uh let's play this clip that so
we can hear it right from Crowder show
because of something to do with Sandy
Hook and a lot of people think that you
were banned from Twitter because of
something to do with Sandy Hook and Elon
clarified that the reason you were
banned from Twitter had to do with that
sniveling worm Oliver Darcy nothing to
do with Sandy Hook but the actual reason
for send him was he he basically
insulted a journalist they platform us
uh for a bunch of madeup crazy stuff the
last thing was Oliver RC later before
they ever sued me they were saying I'm
the Sandy Hook guy and I'm attacking the
families and sending people their houses
and none of it was true and no one was
even going to their houses and people
were peeing on Graves and none it was
true none of that was even shown in
court they were allowed to just get up
and say it with no evidence because I
was already found guilty right and so I
started saying hey I think it happened
I'd already said that by the way I I did
an apology to her on Joe Rogan and
Patrick B David before I even got sued
and said hey here I am years ago saying
I think it happened they said oh now you
admit you lied and did it for money this
was strategic Democratic party PR firm
operation um a lot of people think that
I uh I I think so I think we know for a
fact that right now as we're entering
2024 I mean so this was back in 2018
entering 2024 we have I'm not going to
name the groups and you guys can if you
want to they're these uh uh Democrat PR
Democrat uh uh uh nonprofit 501c4 type
organizations all they do is launch
lawsuits in order to win elections if
you think the 2024 election is simply
how many people can go and cast their
ballot you're wrong a whole lot of it is
going to be procedural fights it's going
to be Court battles and I think a big
component of why not just Alex Jones cuz
it it it was a coordinated move that got
him banned like we we can see him wiped
from every platform instantly but there
were many other people Paul Joseph
Watson got banned from Instagram and
what did he have he had pictures of him
like smoking a cigarette by the sunset
just like ridiculous things like what
are you Banning him for it is political
moving in 2024 I would not be surprised
if we see a ton of moves like this that
being said
with Elon Musk owning X it's going the
other direction we're starting to win
this one especially with other
institutions like Rumble out there now
uh Rumble also has a very interesting
lawsuit against uh some of these you
call them Democratic organizations I
call them more uh government Intel
connected organizations that are also
financed with billionaires individuals
names uh like George Soros who of course
do play a major role in our political
discourse so uh when you see the kind of
coordinated attacks that happened a
couple years ago it it was wasn't social
media it was government officials we
found that out through the Twitter files
we found that out through all the
disclosures we found out that US
government officials FBI officials Intel
officials were saying hey we don't like
what these people are saying shut down
these individual voices they're talking
about this kind of news reporting that
we don't like shut them down immediately
and they did your tax dollars
essentially financed a lot of this and I
really hope that these new lawsuits uh
really shed a light and we have a lot of
discover specifically when it comes to
the larger involvement of outside forces
not just Democratic organizations that
are playing a major role here well you
mentioned Soros and I think that's
actually really crucial part to all of
this because for so long the way that
they got you to not ask questions or
file lawsuits was uh they kind of
associated s insulting Soros criticizing
Soros with you being anti-semitic or you
know calling you names throwing labels
at you and that was actually quite
effective for a few years there I would
say between uh Trump running in 2015 to
about 2019 that was pretty effective to
throw certain labels at you then I think
uh Americans started to wake up by and
large people who weren't even political
by Nature they started to realize okay
these labels don't actually mean
anything because my nextd door neighbors
is being called a racist for having a
Gadson flag or something like that they
started to realize these labels didn't
mean anything then they started actually
investigating it uh who Soros really is
I think more Americans are aware of
these strategies that the left have has
used for so long or just the you know
the uni party at large to silence us
this idea that you can't question
anything Americans are aware more than
ever before that we've been lied to
about not just the government but about
who these people are that we're
surrounded by in our communities and you
know we look around like you know the
people who who were silenced very early
on um and and we're like like Milo
yannopoulos for example or Gavin
McKinnis and it's like these people are
not who they told us they were yeah you
know I I know the exact moment when the
when the tides turned it was when Taylor
Swift called out George Soros several
years ago I I'm half kidding by the way
but Taylor Swift calls out the Soros
family because they undercut her and I
do think that that does open the door a
little bit for people to criticize this
George Soros a lot of conservatives are
attacking Taylor but I'm like dude she
put up this big post talking about how
her music was stolen from it's not
political at all but now well now
there're going to be a lot of people who
are critical of George Soros in a
completely apolitical context you can't
call them all anti-semitic anymore right
and I think that's what it took to bring
it into the mainstream because Taylor is
in the mainstream I think that's a
really really good point I actually
think it's like it's true like I mean
like I think that in order to make
something to be effective you need to
somehow bring it into the mainstream it
can't just be a like political junkie
talking point this is why I think it's a
scop all these conservatives attacking
Taylor Swift because all of a sudden
these accounts on Twitter are like
Taylor's working for George Soros and I
was like what she doesn't like the guy
she's posted against him take the
opportunity man take the win you got I
think this would be a really great video
for Freedom Tunes where it's like a
bunch of 17 18-year-old girls screaming
George Soros ripped off Taylor Swift and
then he's calling them all anti-semites
it's a shame that that guy's not here
but but uh anyway I I I wanted to bring
up another Point here what what we were
just talking about because it was Alex
it was Milo it was Gavin it was Robinson
a lot of big prominent individuals were
censored but more importantly a lot of
kind of smaller upand cominging content
creators were also censored and then
obliterated and had their entire careers
destroyed they weren't the big guys they
weren't the big players that could
sustain these attacks and I I I think
truly the biggest damage that happened
was on all the people that were coming
up that we're going to have an impact
now that we going to be prominent that
we going to be big but had no chance
because the algorithm screwed them over
destroyed them demonetized them and hurt
our kind of discourse more than we could
even imagine parlor would be Twitter
right now exactly that's crazy I it's
like War gaming I mean if we're really
concerned with a war with Russia we have
to look at this as common sense
realistic as possible that these
centralized services are vulnerabilities
like if if Elon holds Twitter on a
central service Verizon can shut him
down the government can go in there and
get his whoever wherever they're hosted
can shut them down they need to
decentralize this service as quick as
possible they need like something like
Brier or Noster or something where we
can run it on our phones decentralized
because this it's it's just inevitable
man because especially with these
infrastructure attacks especially what
what happened to to rumble especially
what and and and what will be happening
probably to Twitter as of course Twitter
also had a lot of very uh important
infrastructure problems and I think the
next step if they can't silence the
person if they can't silence the voice
they're going to silence the megaphone
that people speak through and and these
are the attacks that we should be
keeping an eye out right now well so so
I wonder Elon Musk gives the big Fu at
that New York Times event these
advertisers are are are cancelling and
he says they're going to be the ones
that destroyed this company I think we
we we did briefly mention this a couple
weeks ago Elon Musk could theoretically
just say I am federating X meaning it
will be a decentralized open- source
infrastructure that connects to all the
other other
infrastructure and it will X will never
go anywhere then because now you're
integrated in this decentralized open
source Network he can easily offset tons
of the cost through open sourcing and
distributed uh uh uh uh uh
decentralizing servers and services
through the What's called the ferse and
then there would be a major business
loss the big challenge with this is that
he took got loans to buy X but if x is
on the verge of collapse this may play
out poorly for him but I do think the
richest man whose net worth is currently
as of today estimated $244 billion I
kind of think he can stand to lose $44
billion and it's not just that hold on
like the there's investors involved they
would lose out of money but let's look
let's what's the worst case scenario
Elon says all the advertisers pulled off
in a coordinated fashion for seemingly
political reasons you can't hold me
responsible for that X is now done
what do we do open source decentralizes
our best path to maintain the platform
and retain memberships and and
advertising the me the uh the fediverse
is great although if they stay
centralized on like big data centers or
in in AWS or Cloud wherever they're
hosting that can still get shut out of
the the fediverse so you're looking
versus a mesh Network yeah mesh networks
which are like really up and coming and
they're challenging still to transmit
video cuz they're you know cell phone to
cell phone but you have 50 cell phones
48 of them go down the other two are
still connected with Twitter and then
that's how it'll work but if the
establishment is is really desperate
right and and they're about to lose a
lot of power and they're about to be
held accountable for all the horrible
things they did to us how far do you
think they're going to go to stop that
from happening I think we have to
examine that in a very critical way
because I think they're they're willing
to go very far I think they're willing
to do a lot of crazy things that we
can't even imagine right now to just how
far they will go to say hey um there's
going there's going to be no
accountability here there's going to be
no truth here because as soon as the
people find out the truth it's game over
for them it it's it they're so they're
so cornered they're they're so in a
fragile situation that that truly this
is a very dangerous time for for all of
us yeah I think wherever we're thinking
they're thinking a step ahead like I
think that they're aware that that would
be our plan b or plan C like I I think
they're fully aware of of the direction
this is headed in they wouldn't do the
things that they're doing or they
wouldn't have done the things that they
have done to us for years if they didn't
if they weren't able to think one step
ahead I mean it's the same argument you
can make for Donald Trump everybody's
like well you know we're so back he's
going to win whatever but I
mean it's we're talking about the Deep
State here there's just no there's
nothing that's too far for them I
disagree completely I like the Titanic
can crash into an iceberg you know you
you could you could there's a lot of
conspiracies about that too sure but I'm
us as an analogy I'm not making it
literal if you could build the biggest
ship you can design it to to rip through
ice and then you come across bedrock and
be like we did not expect that that to
happen we calculated and then boom We
tore the hole and now we're sinking it's
possible sure they can see far ahead and
they may be thinking abandoned yeah
there's a lot of Bankers there against
the US Federal Reserve but that's a
different story but I I I do believe uh
that you you could be correct in your
sentiments but but just understanding
how they work and what they did to the
people especially within the last 3
years uh especially with within the last
22 years especially what happened in New
York City when you calculate all of
their moves and decisions nothing is is
out of the real of possibility here to
how far they will go uh to stop people
from finding out what they're really up
to thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net